WELCOME TO THE FIRST ONE OF THE
FIRST SENATE COMMITTEE HEARINGS
OF TWENTY TWENTY HAPPY NEW YEAR
MEMBERS A GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE CODE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES. WE MUST LIMIT NON
ESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS.
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND
I ASK THAT ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE PRESENT ON THE
SENATE FLOOR SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM AS THEY ARE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL ALSO BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I ONE OUNCE AT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN THREE
THREE SIX I'M SORRY THREE THREE
SIX FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT TWO SIX
EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED TO MODERATOR FOR MY
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
SIGN YOU IN LINE NUMBER THIS CAN
BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOU'RE NOT MY
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTE IT AND YOU'RE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE. THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY WE APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM AS WELL DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS NEEDED. WE HAVE. ONE
BILL ON TODAY'S AGENDA. BEFORE
WE THE PRESS. ON THE BILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM PLEASE.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. SENATOR GONZALES HERE GONZALEZ
HERE FAITH. ALAN ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA FEAR FACTOR. CORTELLI
WE'RE TOTALLY HERE DOLLING.
DOLLY HERE DODD DON HRE MY
GRIER HERE MCGUIRE HERE MELINDA
. MAN MAN HERE NEWMAN. HUMAN
HERE RUBIO. SCANNER SCANNER HERE
AMBER. BY CAL SKI FIELD I CAN'T
HERE WELL. OKAY WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM THANK YOU
MADAM CONSULTANT NOW LET'S HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR WE HAVE
SENATOR MCGUIRE HERE WELCOME
SENATOR MCGUIRE YOU MAY PRESENT
YOUR BILL ON SP THREE OH SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR IN THE
MORNING COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE ABLE
TO PRESENT TODAY AT MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS- SP THREE
OF SEVEN IS A CRITICAL BILL THAT
SEEKS TO STOP ONE OF THE LARGEST
ENVIRONMENTAL THREATS THAT THE
STATE IS SEEN. IN THE NORTH
COAST WILL BE WITNESSING
INDICATES. A PROPOSAL FROM A
CLANDESTINE OPERATION HIDING
BEHIND ANONYMOUS LLC OUT OF
WYOMING. THEY WANT TO SHIP
MILLIONS UPON MILLIONS UPON
MILLIONS OF TONS OF COAL.
THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF
CALIFORNIA. INTO THE BAY AREA.
AND THEN UP INTO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE COUNTIES
OF MARIN SONOMA MENDOCINO AND
HUMBOLDT. THAT CALL WITHIN BE
SHIPPED TO ASIAN MARKETS THROUGH
THE PORT OF HUMBLE. SPECIFICALLY
SP THREE OH SEVEN WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIA PREVENTING ALL STATE
FUNDING FROM GOING TO THIS
INITIATIVE. TO BE ABLE TO BLOCK
IMPROVEMENTS ON THE NOW DEFUNCT
NORTH COAST RAIL LINE NORTH OF
THE CITY OF WILLITS. FURTHER
ADVANCE STATE MONEY FROM BEING
SPENT ON THE BUILD OUT OF ANY
NEW BOOK CALLED TERMINAL-FACILITIES WITHIN THE COUNTY OF
HUMBLE. NOW THIS ISSUE FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN THE LEGISLATURE
FOR VET MAY SOUND FAMILIAR TO
YOU SIMILAR LEGISLATION WAS
PASSED- N. IMPACTED SENATOR
SKINNER'S DISTRICT. WIND THEN
SENATOR HANCOCK BROUGHT FORWARD
SENATE BILL TWELVE SEVENTY NINE
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. THAT
ALSO BLOCK FUNDING WHEN A TOXIC
COAL TRAIN COAL TERMINAL
PROPOSED FOR THE PORT OF
OAKLAND. THIS PROPOSED TAX A
COAL TRAIN MOVING TO CURRENT DAY
IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTER IN
THE MAKING. THE MIDWEST COAL
THAT WOULD TRAVEL THROUGH THIS
YEAR'S ACROSS THE GOLDEN STATE
THROUGH THE HERT OF THRIVING
COMMUNITIES ANCIENT REDWOODS
STATE AND NATIONAL WILD LANDS IT
WOULD ALSO RUN ALONG THE RUSSIAN
IN YOUR RIVERS WHICH ARE THE
MAIN SOURCE OF DRINKING WATER
FOR NEARLY ONE MILLION
RESIDENTS. IT'S CRUCIAL THAT WE
STOP THIS DANGEROUS OPERATION
COAL IS THE MOST DAMAGING SOURCE
AND ENERGY ON THE PLANET IT'S
THE NUMBER ONE CONTRIBUTOR HANDS
DOWN. TO OUR CLIMATE CRISIS.
WINDBER COAL SPEWS MRGREEN THE
ATMOSPHERE TO BE RAINED DOWN
UPON OUR COASTS AND WATERWAYS
WERE ACCUMULATES IN FISH.
POISONING PEOPLE WILDLIFE.
ALLOWING INTENSIVE COAL
SHIPMENTS ALONG AS
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE
HABITAT WOULD BE INCONSISTENT
TORE STATES INVESTMENTS IN
MOVING TOWARDS MORE RENEWABLE
ENERGY. THE TOXIC COAL TRAIN IS
OFFICIALLY OPPOSED BY THE
COUNTIES OF HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO
SONOMA AND MARIN THE VAST
MAJORITY CITIES ALONG THE
CORRIDOR INCLUDING INCLUDING THE
CITY SANTA ROSA. CITY PETALUMA
CITY WILLITS CITY YOU CHI AND
THE CITY OF EUREKA AMONG OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE SIERRA CLUB HUMBLE
BEE KEEPER AND THE RUSSIAN. EVER
THE RUSSIAN RIVERKEEPER. I HAVE
WITH ME TODAY AT LEAST YOU'RE
HARMON SHE'S EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF FRIENDS OF THE EEL RIVER
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT MRS HAYMAN
IS WITH US ALONG WITH DANIEL
BRAND REPRESENTING THIS YEAR.
MANAGER WISH FOR CLASS WHEN I
VOTED THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE NINETY
YOU'VE WORKED ON THIS FOR SOME
TIME SO WE APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION. SO WE'LL FIRST
START OFF WITH- MISS HAMMOND
WITH FRIENDS OF THE EEL RIVER I
BELIEVE SHE MAY BE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THIS
IMPORTANT MATTER TODAY- MY NAME
IS LISA HAMMOND I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR FRIENDS OF THE EEL
RIVER AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF SB THREE OF FIVE
AND- LIKE SENATOR MCGUIRE SAID
THE BILL WOULD PREVENT ANY STATE
FUNDING FROM GOING TO HELP COAL
COMPANIES TRANSPORT COAL ON THE
NTRA RAIL RIGHT OF. WAY FROM- OR
FROM HER HUMBLE HARBOR. HEALER
CAN'T IN- PUT SIMPLY JUST NOT AN
APPROPRIATE LOCATION FOR A
RAILROAD WHEN IT WAS LAST
OPERATED OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO THE NORTHWESTERN PACIFIC
RAILROAD. WAS PRONE TO FREQUENT
DERAILMENTS- THE EVIDENCE THAT
MAY STILL LIE IN THE RIVER AND
IT WAS THE MOST EXPENSIVE LINE
IN THE NATION TO MAINTAIN.
RESTORING RAIL SERVICE TO THE
EEL RIVER CANYON WOULD DEVASTATE
THE PROGRESS MADE TOWARDS
FISHERIES RESTORATION AND
REMEDIATION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HARM ON THE RAILROAD. IF YOU HAD
CALLED IN THE EQUATION-
RESIDENTS ON THE NORTH COAST
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO POISONED AIR
AND WATER. THE NEGATIVE IMPACT
OF WHOLE TRANSPORTATION AND
STORAGE ON PUBLIC HEALTH. REALLY
CANNOT BE UNDERSTATED. BECAUSE
OF I THINK ME ABOUT THE IS THE
MIDDLE OF THE PROGRESS. IN
RESTORATION OF THE NORTH TO AND
FISHERIES. AND FRIENDS WOULD BE
AWARE OF AT SUPPORT THE BILL AND
WE'RE WORKING REALLY HARD TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO STOP THE
PRACTICAL TRAINING SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I. IN
. THE THREE OH SEVEN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR TESTIMONY MISS
HAMMOND. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
SECOND SO A WITNESS IN SUPPORT
MR. DANIEL BARRETT WITH SIERRA
CLUB. GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
DANIEL BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA AND-
AFTER MILLION MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WERE INSTRUCTED. AT AT B. THREE
OH SEVEN. STILL IT'S KEY TO
PROTECTING NORTH COAST
COMMUNITIES WATER SAID YOU GOT
THAT DONE AND WHILE BUYERS FROM
A BILLION DOLLAR TOXIC PLANNED.
AND THAT WAS DEVELOPED IN SECRET
BY COAL COMPANY IN THE MIDWEST
TO SHIP COAL THROUGH THE NORTH
COAST. WE'VE ALSO KNOWN FOR
DECADES THAT BURNING CALL HAD TO
REJECT PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACT AND
THEY MASTERED CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. CALIFORNIA
CANNOT BE A LEADER ON CLEAN AIR
AND CLIMATE AND ALSO FACILITATE
THE COMBUSTION OF FOSSIL FUEL
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD. AGAIN
SIERRA CLUB STRONGLY SUPPORTS AT
B. THREE F. SEVEN HUNDRED
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR EYEBROWS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY SO
WE CONCLUDED UR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE WILL
MOVE ON NOW TO ANY WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY. IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE OH SEVEN. THREE NINE OKAY
THEN WE'LL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE IF WE HAVE
ANY. ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE TELECONFERENCE
LIGHT MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY ON SB THREE
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE OH SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I DO HAVE ABOUT THREE
INCH HEELS WE'LL GO TO LINE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR EMBERS GOOD MORNING THIS
VOLUME WE HAVE FOR THE BOARD TO
SUE ROGERS IN MENDOCINO AND
HUMBOLDT COUNTIES IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE OH SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT PLEASE
THANK YOU I DON'T. HERE IS THE
ONE MOMENT FOR THE NEXT COMMENT. NINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO OUT.
NOT INSURING NUMBERS ELENA ORTIZ
ON BEHALF OF FATE THE RECKLESSLY
INTO COURT. THANK YOU LINE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS REGGIE COLLINS AND THE
LEGAL POLICY DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA POLICY- ADDING A-
MEET YOU FROM TROUT UNLIMITED-
AND WE- WE'RE INSTRUCTED BUT
IT'S ACTUALLY DRESS UP. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR I'M HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL THE SUPPORTERS WHO WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS FOR ANY-
WHEN WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION WE DON'T HAVE ANY
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
BUT WE WILL MOVE TO THE GALLERY
SEE NONE. AT THIS TIME. AND THEN
WE WILL MOVE BACK TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE FOR ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE OH SEVEN
. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO ACT. B. THREE
OH SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MODERATOR WE'VE
CONCLUDED SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WE WILL NOT TAKE THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS. ON THE FLOOR FOR SP
THREE OH SEVEN SENATOR TO LEFT
YES I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY. STATING THAT
MY SUPPORT FOR SB THREE OH SEVEN
THE KNOWLEDGE TO WORK THAT THE
AUTHOR IS DONE- MY COLLEAGUE IS
DONE INTENSIVE RESEARCH AND IT'S
BEEN ON THIS FOR I THINK THIS IS
THE SECOND YEAR ON THIS. BUT I
DO HAVE A QUESTION AND CONCERN
AND THAT IS THAT IF WE PASS SB
THREE OH SEVEN BECOMES LAW. AND
WHAT HAPPENS DOWN THE ROAD WHEN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SAYS THEY
THEY NEED THAT RAIL SYSTEM- WILL
THIS BE ABLE TO STOP THAT THAT
IS MY QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCHULETA-
SENATOR MCGUIRE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO RESPOND OUR CHURCH AT THAT IN
YOUR CLOTHES OKAY GENERAL
MANAGER ABSOLUTELY GO RIGHT
AHEAD THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
SHARING THANK YOU SO MUCH-
SYNERGY LETTER FOR THE GREAT
QUESTION. SO FEDERAL REGULATION
PREMIUMS ALL STATE REGULATION.
RAILROADS ARE FEDERALLY
REGULATED UTILITY- AND HERE'S
WHERE WE'RE AT. WE WERE MOVING
FORWARD WITH AN APPLICATION BUT
THE SURFACE TRANSPORTATION BOARD
IN WASHINGTON DC. I LIKE TO RAIL
BANK THE LINE. WELL IT'S- ALL
THE WAY UP TO HUMBLE SOME.
RAILED IS APPROVED BY THE SERVER
TRANSPORTATION BOARD THAT
OVERSEES ALL FREIGHT RAIL FOR-
THE UNITED STATES. IF AT ANY
TIME THERE IS A VIABLE ENTITY.
AS FAR AS A FREIGHT RAIL
OPERATION THAT WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TRANSITION THE TRAIL
BACK TO RAIL. BY LAW WE WOULD
HAVE TO DO SO. I SINCE THE RAIL
BANKING ACT WAS PASSED BY
CONGRESS IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND MILES OF
FREIGHT RAILS BEING TRANSITIONED
INTO TRAILS. LESS THAN TWENTY
MILES OF THAT TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND TOTAL HAS EVER BEEN
TRANSITION BACK FROM TRAIL TO
RAIL. THERE IS NOT BEEN A VIABLE
FREIGHT ENTITY ON THE NORTH
COAST SINCE THIS WAS SHUT DOWN
IN THE EARLY NINETIES. AS WE
HEARD FROM OUR WITNESSES THE
LAST TRAIN THAT WENT UP THE
RIVER CANYON THAT HAS SOME OF
THE MOST GEOLOGIC. GEOLOGICALLY
UNSTABLE SOILS ON EARTH. RAIL
CARS STILL REMAIN IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE RIVER THERE WERE WASHED
OUT FOM THE LINE BY ELAINE SIDE
. CANDIDLY WE WILL NEVER SEE
ANOTHER FREIGHT RAIL GO UP THE
RIVER CANYON IT WILL LITERALLY
TAKE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS MOST
LIKELY WELL OVER TEN BILLION
DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO FIX UP THE
YOU'LL RIVER CANYON SECTION AND
THE SEVEN SECTIONS FOR A VIABLE
FREIGHT OPERATOR. AND IT SIMPLY
WON'T MAKE THE CUT WHEN IT COMES
TO FINANCES. THANK YOU FOR
DEREGULATING THAT AND I THINK
THAT WAS MY POINT TO BE ABLE TO-
HAVE YOU EXPRESS THE DANGER OF
THE RAIL COMING BACK. SO WITH
THAT I URGE- AND I VOTE ON SB
THREE OH SEVEN THANK YOU AND-
ARCHULETA PUSHING THAT A SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU CHAIR- I
WANTED TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING FORTH BILL- WE KNOW
THAT. COAL USE OVERALL IN THE
UNITED STATES IS DROPPED MMHM
WHILE CALIFORNIA CLEARLY HAS A
100% RENEWABLE COAL. FOR
ELECTRICITY GENERATION IN OTHER
STATES DON'T EVEN THOUGH OTHER
STATES DON'T. COAL BASED
GENERATION OF ELECTRICITY HAS
BEEN DROPPING ANNUALLY IN THE
UNITED STATES WHICH IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THE CASE ELSEWHERE
IN THE WORLD SO OF COURSE. ONE
OF THE ONLY MARKETS FOR COAL IS
EXTERNALLY AND- SINCE WE ARE
CLEAR THAT IT IS ONE OF THE MOST
SERIOUS POLLUTANTS WHEN IT COMES
TO THE CLIMATE CRISIS WE DON'T
NECESSARILY WANT TO BE
ASSISTING. HAVING OUR POOL GOING
ELSEWHERE AND BEING BURNT
MEANINGFUL IN GENERATED IN NORTH
AMERICA SO. I THINK IT IS A VERY
WISE- BILL. IN ADDITION TO ITS
PROTECTION OF THE NORTH COAST
AND AS THE SENATOR POINTED OUT A
SIMILAR ACTION WAS TAKEN TO
PREVENT A COAL DEPOT FROM THE
PORT OF AKLAND FOR THE SAME
REASON IT WOULD'VE BEEN COAL
GENERATED ELSEWHERE AND SOLD
THEM TO ASIA. SO WITH THAT I
WILL MOVE THE BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OF PUTTING ASIDE ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS ON COAL HAVE WE AS A
STATE- OTHER LEGISLATION EVER
HAD A BILL THAT WOULD PROHIBIT
ANY STATE MONEY FROM BEING USED
TO REHABILITATE. EXISTING
FACILITIES OR OPERATIONS AS ITS
STAFF REPORT AND CONCEPT
INCLUDING A RAILYARD OR RAIL IF
ANY RAIL INFRASTRUCTURE I GET
THE I GET THE REAL BANKING I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT WE'RE DOING
MORE THAN THAT MORE THAN JUST
CALL WE'RE SAYING WE'LL NEVER
SPEND ANY MONEY ON ANY OF THESE
FACILITIES HAVE WE EVER DONE
THAT TO THE AUTHORS. KNOWLEDGE
SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR INTER THANK YOU SIR BYE
CASKEY UNFORTUNATELY FEDERAL LAW
DOES NOT ALLOW THE STATE. IN
YOUR LOCAL ENTITIES TO BE ABLE
TO SINGLE OUT- INDIVIDUAL USES
OF A RAIL. FOR EXAMPLE COAL AND
OIL IT'S ALL OR NOTHING. AND
THAT IS WHY IT IS STATED AS SUCH
IN THE BILL. UNDER THE PREVIOUS
BILL IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
WHEN THEN SENATOR HANCOCK
ADVANCED HER BILL. IT WAS VERY
FOCUSED ON THE ISSUE OF COAL
TERMINALS- BUT- THERE IS AN
ACTIVE RAIL LINE IN THE PORT
AROUND IN AND AROUND THE PORT OF
OAKLAND THERE IS NOT BEEN AN
ACTIVE RAIL LINES IN THIS
STRETCH FOR. WELL SINCE BEFORE I
WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL SO THIRTY
YEARS AGO- IN SO THAT IS WHY WE
ARE FOCUSED ON RAIL IN IN JUST
BEING CANDID ABOUT IT THERE IS
NO WAY IN HELL. A FREE RAIL LINE
WILL EVER START AGAIN. THROUGH
THE RIVER CANYON IT'S TOO
EXPENSIVE AND THE BUSINESS
SIMPLY IS NOT THERE IN FACT
WE'VE TALKED WITH A HALF DOZEN
FREIGHT OPERATORS THAT SINCE WE
STARTED. ON THE GREAT RED
BETRAYAL OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND NO ONE CAN MAKE THE
BUSINESS CASE TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THE IMPROVEMENTS THAT WILL
LITERALLY DID BE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS- AND- THE FREE OPERATION
SIMPLY IS NOT THERE TO SUSTAIN.
ANY TYPE OF- FUTURE FREIGHT RAIL. OKAY I MEAN I THINK THAT I
JUST WANT. TO SO IF I UNDERSTAND
IN ORDER TO GET THE PROBATION ON
THE WHOLE ELEMENT ON THE LINE
YOU HAVE TO SAY THAT THE STATE
WILL PUT NO MONEY INTO ANY REAL
PREPARATION WHICH IS DIFFERENT
FROM THE HANCOCK BILL BECAUSE-
TECHNICALLY YOU COULD STILL RUN
HOLD UP AND DOWN THE LINE YOU
JUST COULDN'T GET IT TO THE
TERMINAL THAT WAS THE- THAT WAS
THE DIFFERENCE. I GUESS THE
OTHER QUESTION IS I HAVEN'T SAID
THIS IS THE CONTINUOUS LINE SO I
UNDERSTAND THE EAGLE RIVER AS IT
CROSSES THROUGH THE DIFFERENT
SECTIONS HERE BUT LET'S SAY IS A
MINOR IS YOUR INFIRM DALE AND
THE LINE GOES TO ARCADE AND
SOMEBODY WANTS TO USE THAT LINE.
THEY ARE UNDER THE FEDERAL
SYSTEM THEY COULD. AND AGAIN I
DON'T SEE IT ECONOMICALLY MAKING
SENSE RIGHT NOW BUT IN THE
FUTURE THEY COULD GO INTO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. UNDER THERE
ARE REAL BANKING GIVEN EXEMPTION
TO DO THAT UNDER THIS
LEGISLATION NO STATE FUNDS WOULD
BE ALLOWED TO. REHABILITATE THE
RAIL YARD FOR ANY OF THE
FACILITIES THAT WE HAVE TO BE. A
FUTURE LEGISLATURE THAT WOULD
HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT. YOU'RE
CORRECT SIR ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR WHITE
HOUSEKEEPING HE SAID REQUIRED WE
HAVE ONE LAST QUESTION FROM
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS- I REALLY JUST
HAVE A COMMENT MORE THAN IT
QUESTION I I'VE BEEN IN FAVOR OF
RAIL BANKING FOR SOME TIME I
BELIEVE THAT- IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO KEEP THE CORRIDOR
INTACT- WE CAN MAKE TRAILS OUT
OF THEN WE CAN DO WHATEVER BUT
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE
HOLDS A HUNDRED YEARS FROM NOW
WHEN. WE'RE NOT HERE. MAYBE
THERE IS SOME OTHER. USE FOR
THAT CORRIDOR AND IT WOULD BE
MAINTAINED. BUT THIS BILL IS
MORE ABOUT. THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE AS THE STATE LOOKS AT
IT THOSE THOSE DETERMINATIONS
WILL BE DONE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. ON HOW THOSE RAIL BASE
WILL BE USED SO FOR THIS BILL
I'M I'M GONNA SUPPORT IT TODAY
AND THE REASON BEING IS THAT IF
WE'RE GOING TO SPEND ANY OF THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVALABLE TO
CALIFORNIANS THERE'S A LOT
BETTER PLACES THAT WE SHOULD BE
FOCUSING OUR RESOURCES ON- WE
JUST. NO DURING THE BREAK WE HAD
THE- PORTS ANALYSIS I KNOW MANY
OF YOU WERE THERE. WE TALKED
ABOUT GETTING A RAIL LINE FROM
THE PORTS IN SAN DIEGO OUT TO
THE INLAND EMPIRE WHICH WOULD.
REDUCE TRAFFIC IN OUR INNER
CITIES AND ACTUALLY DO GOOD
CARBON WORK. REDUCING CARBON SO
THOSE ARE THE AREAS THAT I THINK
THAT- IF CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO
BE SPENDING RESOURCESWE SHOULD
BE FOCUSING THOSE RESOURCES ON
AREAS WHERE WE KNOW WE CAN.
REDUCE TRUCK TRAFFIC IN OUR
INNER CITIES AND PORTS. AND PUT
RAIL LINES OUT TO- YOU KNOW
INTERMODAL SYSTEMS THAT- WE WORK
OUTSIDE OF OUR CITY SO THAT'S
THE REASON I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL- IN THE FUTURE WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GONNA COME
WE'LL KEEP THAT. REAL BANK TO
WHERE IT SHOULD BE PEOPLE CAN
HIKE THAT HAS A TRAIL FOR NOW
BUT IN THE FUTURE IF IT WANTED
TO BE USED FOR- FEDERAL- ASSESS. THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY I
THINK WE ALREADY HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR SKINNER BUT I WOULD
CONCUR AS WALLICH MET MOST OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT- I'D LIKE TO SAY
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
FOUR PLUS YEARS- IT'S CERTAINLY-
WELL WORTH- THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO ENGAGE IN DISCUSSION AND
CONTINUE TO INFLUENCE THE
PROCESS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AS WELL SO WITH THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THEIR TERRACE ON
TAKE A MOMENT SAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SINCERE AND DIRECT
ENGAGEMENT AT YOUR AMAZING STAFF
TEAM. FOR THEIR SINCERE AND
DIRECT ENGAGEMENT- INTO THIS
COMMITTEE FOR THE CONVERSATION
TODAY CENTER TO LET OUR DENNIS
SKINNER SONORA CASKETS DOLLARS
OUT FOR THIS CONVERSATION IT
WOULD BE GRATEFUL TO HAVE YOUR
SUPPORT TO BE TO STOP THE TOXIC
CULTURING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR REQUIRE WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR SKINNER- IT SO THAT'S
BEEN MOVED. THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS
IS F. B. THREE OH SEVEN REQUIRE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GONZALEZ. HI
CONSOLIDATED BY FAITH. ALAN HI
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI ARCHULETA
HI BECKER. OURTESY ALL RIGHT
COURTESY HI DOLLY DOLLY I DON.
DON HI MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MEN ARE MEN HI NEWMAN
HI NEWMAN HI RUBIO. SCANNER BY
SCANNER ON A NUMBER. WHY CASKEY
HI OUR COUNTY I WILL. HOW MANY.
OKAY IT LOOKS LIKE THE BILL IS
OUT WE WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL AS WELL THOUGH ECAUSE WE
ARE WAITING FOR ANOTHER MEMBER
TO ARRIVE SENTIMENT SENATOR
MCGUIRE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION BUT LOOKS LIKE THE
PHILADELPHIA LEAD ON COLLEGE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I THINK WE'RE
WAITING FOR ONE OTHER SENATOR TO
ARRIVE LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL AS
SHE ARRIVES WE'LL CONTINUE THE-
DISCUSSION THANK YOU EVERYONE.
YEAH. OKAY AT THIS TIME WE'LL
TAKE A BRIEF RECESS WHILE WE
WAIT FOR OUR SENATOR TO ARRIVE
THANK YOU.
HEADING CLOSER ROLE
AT THIS POINT WE HAVE I BELIEVE
ELEVEN EYES AND NOSE. OKAY IT'S
ME ONE MOMENT.
THAT'S OKAY IT
LOOKS LIKE THE BILL IS OUT WITH
ELEVEN ISAN ZERO KNOWS- WE WANT
TO GO AHEAD AND THE SENATE
HEARING ON THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON TRANSPORTATION AND WE WANT TO
THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE GREATLY APPRECIATED WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR PRAYERS
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA. THANK YOU.